[Music]
and welcome back to Hannity we are
broadcasting live tonight beautiful
Davenport Iowa thank you all for coming
we continue now with former president
Donald Trump as we now head into the
Iowa caucus season a two-part question
on Joe Biden one is about his cognitive
decline and the second is about the
Biden family Syndicate as I call it
let's first play an RNC ad about Joe
Biden take a look but the
nature
not
[Music]
when the political coverage
the that
look
um some of the
political players and some of the
uh let me ask a rhetorical
question no I won't any
anyway now there's all I could play tape
from almost every day I I think another
horrible moment for him was that gagle
on Air Force One after he left Israel so
my question is what do you think about
his cognitive State and number two the
issue of Hunter Biden Joe Biden lying to
the country as a candidate and president
I never had a discussion with hunter or
my brother or anybody for that matter on
foreign business deals we know according
to Deon Archer he was on phone calls we
know he was meeting with oligarchs like
the former P Lady of Moscow at Cafe
Milano um doesn't seem to get the
attention in the media that anything
involving you gets what is your reaction
to both well you know uh they've been
after all of my numbers and facts and
figures and they found out that uh it
was incredible somebody said you must be
the most honest guy in the world because
after all these years and they saw
everything my tax returns they saw
everything went up to the ceiling and
they saw it uh he is number one from
your standpoint cognitively you like to
use that word cognitively he's not good
but it's not for me to say I will say
this I just saw a commercial by these Lo
lives where they took me imitating him
at a speech where we were all having a
lot of fun it's not really fun because
we shouldn't be joking about it I
actually told Sean Sean you shouldn't
joke about it it's serious we're dealing
with nuclear we're dealing by the way
that is a true story you actually called
me and said it's not funny cuz I was
about it that's not funny I said I
thought about it and I said you're right
and I said how come you never listen to
my
advice but it's true that's it's
actually true unfortunate but you know I
so I imitated him not finding his way
off a stage it's not really that hard
you're looking around and I walk into a
wall I say let me see you and I do that
a lot you know I just sort of at some of
our uh rallies and then I'll say our
real president is Barack Hussein Obama
they'll say he doesn't know who the
president is he thinks it's Barack who
say no I'm being sarcastic they so they
imitate it but they're disgraceful I'll
tell you what we are dealing and you are
dealing I got to know them all the
leaders of the world I got to know them
all and they're at the top of their game
some are bad people some are decent
people they all have one thing in common
they want what's good for their country
whether it's president she of China or
Kim Jong-un of North Korea saved I you
would have been if Hillary got in you
would have been in nuclear war that
would have been a nuclear war uh any one
of them they're all including macron of
France I mean you can go to any of them
Putin they're at the top of their game
we have somebody that was never at the
top of his game 25 years ago he wasn't
one of the light bulbs he wasn't one of
the bright ones and I tell I tell the
story so Ted Kennedy believe it or not
was a friend of mine because of Palm
Beach they lived in Palm Beach at What's
called the Kennedy Compound and I once I
did him a big favor one time and somehow
he liked me I liked him even though we
were opposite in many ways politically
certainly and I said to him who's the
smartest guy in the Senate and he gave
me a name I don't want to tell you
because I really don't like the guy at
all still around I said who's the
dumbest he said probably Joe I said
who's Joe Joe Biden it's the first time
I said uh huh and that was it and now I
see when he's not in prime time for
himself I mean years later he failed on
being president when was like normal
some something is going wrong and we
can't afford it because we have a
problem today nuclear weapons is the
single biggest problem the world has and
we have people you know it used to be 10
years ago even five years ago even three
years ago nobody would have thought
about nuclear you couldn't mention the
word now it's being mentioned at every
meeting every time you talk it's being
mentioned the level of power of the
nuclear weapons is incredible like take
Hiroshima or take Nagasaki and you look
and that was many many decades ago and
multiply that times 500 that's what a
big bomb would be today whether it's
Israel or M really major
countries nuclear weapons are the
biggest problem we have and we have a
man that can't put two sentences
together we have a man that doesn't know
he's alive and he's backed up by the
media the biggest problem we have the
media the media is fake I came up with a
term a long time ago and they won't talk
about
it let me ask you this if I did some of
the things that he did they' reinstitute
the death penalty okay they don't want
to talk about it when he gets paid $3.5
million from the mayor of moscow's wife
when I brought it up at a debate and
Chris Wallace was moderating how's he
doing by the way not too good Chris
Wallace what have happened to Chris
Wallace and I said why is he getting
$3.5 million I want to ask asked him
that question and Chris Wallace
interceded because Joe didn't know he
was alive and so Chris Wallace
interceded and he said and he said you
shouldn't be asking that you and now
it's a big subject and I talked about it
literally three years ago but why does
all this money come in from China you
know we took in hundreds of billions of
dollars in taxes and tariffs from China
we gave the farmers by the way $28
billion that's why I say I'm going to
win
Iowa I had my people my people say
please sir don't keep saying you're
going to win Iowa you sound so really
horrible crash somebody said crash I
said but it's true we're going to win
Iowa I gave the farmers $28 billion and
I got her from China who else could do
that who else would be able to do it
number one who else would think about it
I think about it because the farmers
were hurt very badly by China for many
years and I asked our secretary of
agriculture sunny pdue I said Sunny how
much damage has been done over the past
7 years8 years he came back $28 billion
I said I'm getting it from China and I
got it and I told the farmers go out and
buy more land and go out and buy bigger
tractors right you remember that and I
said I'm going to win Iowa cuz nobody
else is going to be able to do that hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else